[Musique]
dis moi ça vous va comme ça où tu veux
ou c'est trop long da sera la célébrité
parce que c'est à la fois agréable les
gens gentils dans la rue vous sourit ou
fond on sent une complicité avec eux
c'est sympa mais c'est compliqué d'être
célèbre parce qu'on remarque tout ce que
vous faites
on vous surveille on regarde même ce que
vous mangez qui avec qui vous parlez
avec qui vous sortez et heureusement moi
je ne bois pas et je ne sors pas donc
j'ai pas de problème comme certains
camarades btp mp d'être bourrée le soir
aux yeux de tous dar k grosse d'arc à
marrakech et je crois que c'est une
ville préférée c'est une des plus proche
de paris
quand on décide de prendre l'avion
évidemment et puis ça me coûte moins
cher de la marrakech qu'à bordeaux
chaebols les humer race les uv passera
jamais secteu monde croît grâce à notre
ami cyril je n'ai jamais fait de ma vie
voilà je les laisse les poils je suis un
brin poilus d'origine méditerranéenne et
j'en ai d'arca le métro d'arc à tous les
jours je prends le métro prenait à la
radio tous les jours je sais que tout le
monde est surpris avec ça parce que
parce que quoi bein oui je prends le
métro on ne reconnaît dans le métro oui
bien sûr mais bon ça va toujours des
petits regards complices un passé bon
d'arc à l'elysée d'arc à hacker lives et
de melide arcade arcade arcade harkat
avait quelques heures je trouve cette
fille belle adorable
intentionnés bienveillante un amour
c'était il ya l'amour
alors quand j'étais jeune pour les
soirées mondaines d'arc à un grosse
d'arca je rêvais d'être invité je me
sentais toujours rejeté en revanche
maintenant que ça fait trente trois ans
ou même peut-être plus que je suis dans
le circuit passera vraiment d'arca je
les aime beaucoup je le trouve très
cultivé très bienveillant aussi très
gentilles c'est un mec bien
[Musique]